[Music] the Bruins control the game
is [Music] on Mason Raymond seeking
working in a spectacular save Zone that gets
disrupted turnover happens look like the Bros
are going to get back right here but makoy
can't settle it down that gets chipped away
from him all of a sudden Swan's going to make
a [Music] stop three games or of two or more
goals Cole wins the draw but to Bret pounces
on the puck Len against makavo feeds to br
going to look at just why the Bruins going
to be shorthanded after the Great great stop
by San on to Bret nice little toe drag by
Maron and a save by San post closes a save
BYO UT keeps it in Maran poock makoy
the onetime with Dan Reams Dy on the
doorstep fourman from on the near boards P
slides to makavo Van reight to zaka and H the
post and oh tough break there and then he makes
a nice play to zaka who's the bumper they create
that two on one Zeno nearby zaka Van reik post
knock maoy marshan a onetime blocked by sherat
van reik a physical presence marshan
to van reik and zaka pokes it
home what Puck movement what pursuit of the
puck and there's that retrieval right there
V re like had a monster shift in every
aspect of working the front of the net
and then getting to the loose pucks when
they when they are off net and zaka does
a great job as well in his role middle of the
ice in the bumper we showed you the one real
good chance that he had well they not going
to be denied there again Ben reek at the top
of the crease looking for a redirect playing
here in Boston and given the with the roster
Turtle great save by Swan beer guns it off the
boards go is bear can't flatten the park not avoid
goes right to goal and it's in Charlie maoy with
a flying or imitation across the goal mou makes it
two Z when you want to pick this up you can pick
it up right here with makoy pitches down that's a
good read what's available everybody's kind of
in man-on-man coverage so maoy knowing he has
separation around gos I'm just going to take this
puff to the net hopefully I get a good bounce if I
don't get a clean backand her away that's exactly
what he got hot but the whole line brown and Ste
and be are keeping the puck in the offensive
zone with good Puck pursuit to allow the D to be
active3 gains the line drops it
to marshan the shot Saka denied
twice Maran assist
atock poock sh his stud and
reik good Puck retrieval the
puck bounces past makoy Comer Insider
coner saved by Swan Maran cuts to the
inside B knock swings it over gets
it back from Lind home off the end
boards [Applause] sherat cider
to shurat scales it one skip in
on H hotr Jake debrus up front
with Lindholm and grizzli the
D pair Shane gs's spar dangerous
in such situations shat angles it
off DK lone sends out the studs the Lin line
and Jim Montgomery counters with the zaka
line poster knock breaks in a saving poke
check by Jake wman Lin muffled by grizzli
a kick save by swayan old school kicking it
out staying on his skates poock Maneuvers
through the slot wman for a knee yeah he was
actually trying to slide that puck off that
far post of charie maoy zacha bomb Joe Veno
wins to draw he has scored four goals in his
last four games his career high for a season is
nine and he scores his fifth in five games when
you're hot you're hot a perfect shot game
a little bit more energy in the offensive
zone Boston not executing with the puck they
turn it over in the neutral zone Leno makes
a pretty good individual effort running turn
through the neutral zone gets his speed [Music]
going clev C gains the line off the post
Detroit came a couple of inches getting
beat with speed through neutral zone they got
numbers you got to give up the Blue Line C's
going to drag snap one through the stick and
it may have changed the the direction of the
shot when the Bruins from two goals
down in the third period yeah again
loosen coverage loosen structure in the
neutral zone will he go for the hidden
shot POS knock with the puck on his hip and
scores torture chamber from behind the penalty
shot is awarded he's going to slow it down right
between the hash marks this might be his
best move he certainly likes it the pump
fig get the golender to fight a little bit just
enough to get down into that butterfly and then
elevates to the [Applause] par Oscar Steen
one on four [Applause] challenges p swats
it off Lin stick and P deliberately clears it in
it's a billiard shot into the empty [Applause] net
I mean great effort down low high marks to
Carlo High marks to De brus they worked in
tail off in the corner not allowing anything
clean to the slot area looks like they might
be able to make a play to line Bruins get back
on the winning track Detroit will lose its third
and [Music] row the Bruins increase their record
to 70 and one equaling the best start since 1938